[Music]
neon was hugely popular in the 30s 40s
in the early 50s with the advent of LED
signs a lot of the small neon shops
folded it's important to me to keep me
out of life
because I feel like there's so much more
that can be done with it I'm Kirk
cunningly and I'm a neon artist and a
neon tube bender I started doing me on
making three-dimensional sculpture while
I was in college and now I've been
working with neon for 38 years in the
Austin area I probably have 75 or 100
neon sign and I've probably made 500 or
600 signs in my career different signs
take different amounts of time there are
more elaborate signs where the glass
work could take 25 or 40 hours to make a
neon light is a really simple process
there's two torches one is used to make
curves and the other one make sharper
angle each Bend is heated up and brought
to the pattern and formed and then
marked where your next Bend is when the
glasses heat is up
you cork off one end of the glass tube
and in the other end I have a rubber
hose and as you bend it you blow into
the glass to keep inside of the tube
uniform
it's a back-and-forth process from torch
to pattern something I really love about
neon lights is the wow factor if you put
up a display even a simple display it
excites people there's nothing that
looks better than neon lights at night I
think it's important that people keep up
the tradition of bending glass
[Music]
you
you